안녕하세요, 저는 Olivia Lanes예요. 양자 컴퓨팅 실전 강좌에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 오늘은 에피소드 2, Quantum
circuits편이에요. 오늘 강의에서는 여러 주제를 다룰 건데요, 여러분이 꼭 알고 가셨으면 하는 세 가지가 있어요. 첫 번째는 IBM
양자 컴퓨터가 실제로 어떤 건지예요. 클라우드를 통해 작업을 보낼 때 머릿속에 대략적인 그림이라도 그릴 수 있도록요.
두 번째는 Qiskit이 뭔지, Primitives가 뭔지, 그리고 이걸 어떻게 활용해서 Quantum circuits를 만들고 실행하는지예요.
IBM Quantum 프로세서의 종류와 각각의 차이점에 대해서도 큰 그림에서 살펴볼 거예요. 그리고 세 번째는
대규모 실험을 실행하기 위해 따르는 일반적인 워크플로우예요. 여기에는 최적의 Primitives 선택이 포함돼요.
여러분의 용도에 맞게 문제를 Quantum circuit에 매핑하고, 오류 억제 및 완화를 적용하는 것도 포함되는데, 이를 통해
이 기계들에서 최대한의 성능을 뽑아낼 수 있어요. 정보가 많긴 하지만 저와 함께 계속 가봐요.
곧 실제 예시들을 통해 모든 걸 종합해서 볼 거예요. 먼저 qubit과 실제 Quantum
하드웨어에 대해 간단히 살펴봐요. 실험가로서 말씀드리면, 정말 매력적인 분야예요. 점들을 연결하는 데 실제로 큰 도움이 되거든요.
클라우드를 통해 양자 컴퓨터에 작업이 전송될 때 실제로 어떤 일이 일어나는지 시각화할 수 있어요. 우리가
사용할 프로세서들은 초전도 트랜스몬 qubit으로 만들어져 있어요. 작은 IBM quantum 프로세서가 어떻게 생겼는지 보여드릴게요.
여기 작은 사각형들이 바로 qubit들이에요. 이 칩에는 총 다섯 개가 있어요. 트랜스몬은
커패시터인데, 비선형 인덕터인 조세프슨 접합과 병렬로 연결된 두 개의 금속판으로 구성돼 있어요.
조세프슨 접합을 보려면 훨씬 더 확대해야 해요. 두 개의
초전도 금속 층이 겹쳐진 곳에서 만들어지는데, 두 부분이 겹쳐서 닿는 곳이 접합부예요. 조세프슨
접합은 여러 에너지 레벨을 가진 인공 원자를 만드는 데 사용되는 소자예요. 우리는
아래쪽 두 에너지 레벨을 qubit 상태로 격리해요. 여기 구불구불한 선들은 마이크로파 공진기를 나타내는데,
기본적으로 qubit에 결합된 2D 전송선이에요. 이제 gate를 프로그래밍할 때 이건 기본적으로
정밀하게 보정된 마이크로파 펄스를 선택하는 거예요. 그 펄스의 특정 주파수, 진폭, 형태, 지속 시간이
qubit이 특정 동작을 하게 만들어요. 마이크로파 펄스에 대한 명령은 여러분의 컴퓨터에서 클라우드로 전달되고,
그런 다음 실온 제어 전자 장치가 읽고 해석해서 그 명령을 물리적으로
펄스로 생성해요. 이걸 마이크로파 펄스라고 부르는 건 전부 마이크로파 주파수 대역 안에 있기 때문이에요.
대략 1GHz 정도예요. 실온 제어 박스에서 펄스가 만들어지면 케이블을 통해 이동해요.
희석 냉동기를 거쳐 최종적으로 Quantum 칩에 도달해요. 신호는 공진기로 들어가는데,
이 패드 위의 와이어 본드를 통해 들어가서 전송선을 따라 qubit으로 흘러가요. 이게 조금
기술적으로 느껴질 수 있고, 앞으로 나아가는 데 이 세부 사항들을 꼭 이해해야 하는 건 아니에요. 하지만 이제
여러분 모두가 곧 상호작용하게 될 물리적 시스템을 어느 정도 머릿속에 그릴 수 있게 됐으면 해요. 그럼 이 양자 컴퓨터들은
실제로 어디에 있을까요? IBM은 전 세계에 수십 대의 양자 컴퓨터를 보유하고 있어요. 최근에는 Fleet을
100qubit 이상 프로세서로만 업그레이드했어요. 이전 강의에서 말씀드렸듯이, 일부는 IBM의
Quantum 데이터 센터(뉴욕 업스테이트)에 위치해 있어요. 그 시스템들은 모든 사람이 사용할 수 있도록 클라우드 전반에 배포돼 있고, 일부는
파트너사를 지원하는 온프레미스 전용 시스템으로, 작동에 필요한 모든 전자 장비를 갖추고 있어요.
IBM quantum 네트워크에 속한 파트너사들을 위한 거예요. 이제 Qiskit에 대해 얘기해 볼게요. IBM의 오픈소스 소프트웨어 개발 키트예요.
양자 컴퓨터에서 작동하도록 설계됐어요. 앞으로는 이걸 Qiskit SDK라고 부를게요. Qiskit
생태계도 있는데, Qiskit의 핵심 기능을 기반으로 하거나 확장하는 소프트웨어, 튜토리얼, 기능들의 모음이에요. 그리고 Qiskit
runtime도 있어요. 이건 사용자가 Quantum 워크로드를 설계하고 효율적으로
실행할 수 있게 해주는 Quantum Computing 서비스이자 프로그래밍 모델이에요. Qiskit Primitives를 사용하는데요, Primitive는 기본적으로 작은 빌딩 블록이에요.
더 큰 circuit이나 작업을 설계하는 데 사용할 수 있어요. 우리에게 가장 중요한 두 Primitive는
sampler와 estimator인데, 곧 더 자세히 다룰 거예요. Qiskit SDK를 아직 다운로드하고 설치하지 않으셨다면,
지금이 딱 좋은 때예요. Qiskit 1.0이 최근 출시됐는데, 이전보다 훨씬 더 성능이 좋고
안정적이에요. 막 시작하시는 분들에게는 정말 좋은 타이밍에 오신 거예요. 이미 Qiskit에 익숙하신 분들은
최신 버전을 다운로드해서 재설치하셔야 해요. pip을 사용해서 Qiskit과 Qiskit runtime을 설치하고,
원하는 웹 브라우저에서 Jupyter 노트북을 통해 실행하는 걸 권장해요. 그래서 Jupyter notebook이나 Jupyter lab도
설치하셔야 해요. 아직 안 하셨다면요. 이 도구들은 모두 무료예요.
비용 없이 여러분의 로컬 머신에서 실행할 수 있어요. visualization 옵션 의존성과 함께 Qiskit을 추가해서
Jupyter에서 잘 작동하고 플롯을 그릴 수 있게 해야 해요. 가상 Python 환경도 설정해야 하는데,
여기에 링크된 Qiskit 설치 페이지에 방법이 나와 있어요. Qiskit에 익숙해지고
실제 양자 컴퓨터에서 작업을 실행할 준비가 됐다면 quantum.com에 등록하고 IBM Quantum
API 토큰을 만들어야 해요. 이에 대한 링크도 여기 있어요. 이 방법에 대한 자세한 안내는
제가 말씀드린 것처럼 문서 페이지의 모든 지침을 따라가시거나, 여기 있는 Qiskit 설치 코딩 영상을 보셔도 돼요.
두 곳 다 설명란에 링크가 있어요. 이제 Quantum
circuits에 대해 얘기할 준비가 거의 다 됐어요. 이 강좌의 목적은 여러분이 100qubit 이상의 규모로
작업을 실행할 수 있도록 가르치는 거예요. 그러기 위해 가장 효과적인 방법은 먼저 우리가 따를 전체 워크플로우를 살펴보는 거라고 생각해요. 이를 이해하는 가장 쉬운 방법이
Qiskit patterns예요. Qiskit patterns는 사용자가 모듈식 툴링으로 특정 단계를 구현해서 Quantum
워크로드를 실행할 수 있게 해주는 개념적 프레임워크예요. 이를 통해 Quantum Computing 작업이
강력한 이기종 컴퓨팅 인프라로 수행될 수 있어요. 이 단계들은 서비스로 수행될 수 있고
리소스 관리를 포함할 수 있어요. 이를 통해 새로운 기능이 개발됨에 따라 원활하게 구성될 수 있어요. 여기
주요 단계들이 있는데, 경험 있는 Qiskit 사용자라면 이미 알고 계실 거예요. 첫 번째 단계는 매핑이에요. 이 단계에서는
관심 있는 일반적인 문제를 어떻게 양자 컴퓨터에
circuit 형태로 매핑할지 공식화해요. 다음은 최적화예요. 이 단계에서는 Qiskit transpiler를 사용해서 circuit을 라우팅하고
실제 물리적 Quantum 하드웨어에 배치해요. 여기에는 개별 Quantum gate를 시퀀스로 변환하는 것도 포함돼요.